- Le décor est prêt.
La Commission Rouleau entame
six semaines d'audiences.
Dans la salle, des organisat
du convoi de camionneurs sont
bien visibles.
(en anglais)
Tamara , , , accusée
de plusieurs méfaits en lien
avec les manifestations, promet
d'être là tous les jours.
Elle sera éventuellement appelée
à dr r r sa version des faits,
comme une soixantaine de témoins
incluant des responsables
gouvernementaux, des policiers
et des experts. Le commissaire e
à établir les faits.
PAUL ROULEAU, commissaire
Commission sur l'état d'urgence
- Les audiences offriront
un processus impartial.
- Son mandat : comprendre
pourquoi le gouvernement fédérae
face aux manifestations...
(klaxon)
... comment il a utilisé
ces pouvoirs spéciaux et si
ses actions étaient appropriées.
À la fin, le commissaire
pourrait recommander
des changements à la loi.
La tâche est colossale :
beaucoup de témoins et
des milliers de documents
à analyser, tout ça en peu
de temps.
Paul Rouleau déplore l'accès
difficile et tardif aux
documents gouvernementaux.
- Bon nombre de ces documents
remis à la commission sont
classifiés sous réserve de la
sécurité nationale ou d'autres
reveatatations de privilèges.
- D'entrée de jeu, les avocats
des différents intervenants ont
étalé leurs positions.
s s s mesures d'urgence étaient
justifiées selon ceux
du gouvernement fédéral...
... qui évoquent une menace
à la sécurité du Canada,
les conséquences des blocages
illégaux et l'intimidation
à l'endroit des résidents
d'Ottawa.
Mais la police provinciale
de l'Ontario croit au contraire
que les pouvoirs spéciaux
étaient superflus et que
les policiers disposaient
de tous les outils
pour faire leur travail.
Les provinces de l'Alberta
et de la Saskatchewan affirment
ne pas avoir été consultées
convenablement par Ottawa sur
le recours aux mes d d d'urgence
tel que l'exige la loi, comme si
la décision était déjà prise.
Justin Trudeau et ses ministres
viendront s'expliquer lors
des deuxnininières semaines
d'audience en novembre.
Le commissaire a rappelé
que le gouvernement Trudeau
a lelele premier à utiliser la
Loi sur les mesures d'urgence.
Selon lui, il y a donc un grand
intérêt public à déterminersi cx
ont été utilisés convenablement.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Ottawa.